за Маріуполь і Бучу за Дніпро і
Станіславський кручі Міністерство
внутрішніх справ України формує
спеціальні елітні бойові підрозділи які
повертатимуть Україні її землі це
проморолик так званої Гвардії наступу
проєкту МВС України за яким до
українського війська набирають вісім
штурмо
вих бесід що за перші два тижні
ініціативи українці подали понад 15
тисяч заявок кілька сотень з них уже
потрапили на навчання охочі самі
заповнюють анкету онлайн або особисто у
центрах надання адмінпослуг у своєму
місті як це сьогодні робить 29-річна
Юлія через військомат коли подаєш там
вони кажуть ну почекайте подумайте може
ви передумаєте А може вам сюди не треба
А ми вас можемо там на блокпост
поставити тут швидше відправляють на
навчання зараз Мене несе саме туди от я
відчуваю що от я маю бути там
активно беруть участь у відборі каже
інспекторка Бри
гади ну йде не знає попереду кілька
етапів конкурсу це фізична підготовка Ну
я займаюсь раніше боксом трохи займалася
десь років два Я вважаю що його готова
потім іде тестування медичне обстеження
перевірка рівня фізичної підготовки
тестування особистісних характеристик
співбесіда з поліцейського комісією
також спецпроект
кожній області це проходить дуже активно
і на сьогодні я вам можу сказати що
навіть зараз ми відкрили ще додатковий
конкурс по Київській області на посаду
поліцейських які в подальшому будуть
направлятися в бригаду Лють і це вже
буде резервами відповідним бо
бажаючих дуже багато
загальна мобілізація на базі
територіальних центрів комплектування та
соціальної підтримки безперервно триває
з 24 лютого 2022 року як активно долав
ЗСУ набирають військовозобов'язаних який
відсоток добровольців станом на сьогодні
на ці запитання протягом кількох тижнів
після запиту ДВ у Київському міському
ТЦК та у командуванні сухопутних військ
відповідей не надали пояснюю це
міркуванні ми безпеки
України
соцмережах час від часу шириться відео
як у різних регіонах українцям як
стверджують автори контенту вручають
поїздки десь доходить до бійки десь
видно як невідомі чоловіки у формі
тягнуть цивільного у броньований
мікроавтобус або не вручають повістки а
одразу заламують руки попросити
Отпустить його що ви його ловив і що за
руким чи що
такими кадрами українці обмінюються у
спеціальних телеграм-каналах де
адміністратори повідомляють як і коли
роздають повістки представники
військкоматів чи справді це так для ДВ
прокоментував секретар РНБО Олексій
Данилов мовляв якщо кадрів мережі
правдиві то це поодинокі випадки а
загальна мобілізація відбувається за
планом наше військове наше сили безпеки
оборони які безпосередньо приймають
участь в цьому процесі вони залучають
таку кількість громадян які вважають і
необхідна для виконання тих завдань які
є на сьогодні і ніякої трагедії ніяких
Скажімо так от форс-мажорів вона в
даному випадку немає вона іде у нас за
планом спокійно рівно виважена і вже
буде рік Ви не бачили Скажем так такого
щоб було би якось там е-е речей які
виходили за межі чи є поодинокі випадки
там де буде несповна розуму роблять ті
речі які точно робити не треба Ну це
трапляється але це поодинокі випадки Я
хочу звернути увагу що це не є якась
масована така ситуація адвокат Єресько
підтверджує це ініціатива в лапках на
місцях і навіть один з місцевих одеських
ТЦК на своїй сторінці в Facebook там
виклав що певні застереження громадянам
що ми так робили і будемо робити Ну
власне зараз з ініціативи оперативного
командування південь Наскільки я знаю
відбувається слідчі дії якщо дивитися з
точки зору закону представники ТЦК не
мають права нікого хапати і нікого
тягнути і при час вручення повістки
насправді
Чи взяв громадянин цю повістку чи не
взяв він же нічого не порушує тому
відповідно і хапати його кудись тягнути
навіть поліція Не дуже то може тому що в
даний момент відбувається жодного
правопорушення адвокат Тарас Єресько
підтверджує клієнти дедалі частіше
запитують юристів як поводитися у разі
вручення повістки на вулиці нерідко
звертається громадяни яким вручали
документ помилково тобто Ті хто має
відстрочку від призову люди з
інвалідністю багатодітні батьки студенти
або люди віком 60+.»
[музика]
і тому відбувається це спонтанна якась
вручення істерія зрученням повісток
для обліку і так звана бойова повістка
після якої військовозобов'язаний за умов
допущення до служби відправляється на
навчання
за законом вручати поїздку можуть буть
де втім лише особисто передача повістки
через родичів або інших третіх осіб є
порушенням з боку ТЦК літні бувають
випадки до прикладу буквально тижнів два
назад бачили як клеїли повістки на
дверях будинку чи квартири Тобто це не
належне оповіщення Якщо повістка
оформлена і вручена законно відмова
громадянина приймати її має фіксуватися
у спеціальному акції та направлятися до
суду якщо мова йде про повістки на
уточнення від військово-облікових даних
тут застосовується адміністративна
відповідальність і максимум покарання
яке може бути це штраф якщо ми вже
говоримо про уникнення наприклад від
мобілізації ухилення від мобілізації
коли вже вручили особі бойову повістку і
Ухиляється особи тоді ми вже можемо
давайте про якусь кримінальну
відповідальність от буквально недавно
читала інформацію що в Хмельницькому
здається був свіжий вирок і позбавили
особу волі на три роки за даними
судового реєстру України у грудні 2022
року справ про ухилянтів стало в
десятеро менше у порівнянні з березням
19 проваджень за місяць на думку радника
голови офісу президента України Михайла
подоляка українці призовного віку мають
нарешті зрозуміти що мобілізація під час
війни критично необхідна для захисту
країни і що просто переказати гроші на
ЗСУ недостатньо
мобілізація країни під час війни це
готовність країни захищатись це
тренування тренування іще раз тренування
це треба щоб людина була свідомо того
щоб вона не ховалася від розуміння що
треба навчитись користуватись зброєю що
треба навчитись елементарних речей
що треба вміти вбивати бо це
психологічно складно оце треба людям
пояснювати і ми недостатньо жорстко це
робили і я вважаю що це помилка тому що
ми вважали Ну я особисто що суспільство
настільки В нас дорослих що може само
між собою обговорювати всі ці складні
речі і я ще раз кажу це не питання
патріотизму до НАТО це питання
усвідомлення того що Росія має програти
які мають усвідомити на фронті необхідна
заміна
це
військовослужбовець засу із позивним
фанат він керує ротою бійців на одному з
напрямків фронту каже багато його
підлеглих не мали відпусток від першого
дня повномасштабного вторгнення у мене
відпустки не було як
крайній раз був
перед війною за два тижні
і То я не до гуляв її мене викликали
на службу не тільки в мене всіх
викликали на службу тоді ніхто не
доголяв свою відпустки і коли я і до
гуляю невідомо нікому взагалі нікому
виведення підрозділу із зони бойових дій
це ротація при відсутності відпусток за
цілий рік повномасштабної війни у роти
фаната була одна єдина ротація в січні
тривалість у місяць Разом з тим прихід
новобранців геть не означає що
досвідчені бійці відпочиватимуть більше
адже новачків треба додатково навчати в
умовах фронту каже фанат коли приходить
дуже багато нових прибули хто їх треба
навчати і на це треба часу що важливо і
час набору людей мотивація все треба щоб
не тягнули за руки військомат чи за вуха
знаєш що буде саме йшли
і важливо щоб всі люди були начені не
гірше тих що зараз є у нас
нещодавно у соцмережах з'явилася новина
про загибель на фронті одного з бійців
ЗСУ Богдана покідко з Тернопільщини за
словами журналіста Юрія Бутусова
чоловіка відправили на передову
недостатньо підготованим днями
представник президента у Верховній Раді
Федір веніславський заявив що подібні
випадки які загальні питання процесу
мобілізації Влада не лишить без уваги у
парламенті вже зареєстрували
законопроект Про внесення змін до статті
закону про військовий обов'язок і
військову службу а саме щодо
встановлення мінімального обов'язкового
терміну підготовки військових після
мобілізації перед відправкою на фронт